good morning to everyone it's morning
here in the Netherlands right now uh I
have already shared my screen I think so
I'll put my slides up uh and
let's go into into presentation mode so
I hope uh that's the slides apologies
Narendra I cannot seem to be oh perhaps
it's some issue on my end apologies yeah
please continue okay so so so we have
the slides on there now
okay uh so I'm assuming we have the
slides up there uh and I will begin
um so I will talk to you today about uh
how we can build interpretable and
realistic generative models uh using
likelihood free Bayesian inference uh so
there is a lot to unpack in this title
what's likelihood free Bayesian
inference and what sort of interpretable
and realistic generative models are we
talking about we will go through that in
the talk
um but before beginning with the with
the serious stuff a little bit about
myself uh I am a research scientist at
Philips research in Eindhoven in the
Netherlands and I have worked in a
variety of data science domains which
range from from sort and recommendations
uh and NLP to marketing budget
optimization
uh previously before I was working at
Philips I did my PhD
um in Neuroscience from Brandeis
University and I also worked as an ml
scientist at TripAdvisor for a couple of
years uh and at this time I was living
in Boston in the US where I lived for
about a decade
um I am a long time Asian and my uh my
foray into Beijing inference began uh
during my PhD and has continued into my
industry work as well
um I also love cycling which is a love
that started while I was living in
Boston uh and now living in the
Netherlands I'm I'm learning more about
about bicycles and sustainable transport
and uh feel free to visit my website to
learn more about me
this this talk is based uh on a research
project which I'll be running through as
an example uh which has uh which is a
very collaborative research project with
all these peoples so we have I mean
rahimian who is an assistant professor
at the University of Pittsburgh uh
shravasti Banerjee who is an assistant
professor in tilburg University here in
the Netherlands and Diego Sanchez Perez
who is our research assistant through
the tilburg science sub also in tilburg
University
um so with that to begin I want to
present to you the idea that we can
think about two different kinds of
machine learning models and models can
be discriminative or they can be
generative so what I mean by that is
discriminative models are those that can
differentiate between different classes
of targets so they can based on the
inputs they can produce targets of
different kinds whereas generative
models are those that can generate uh
the data points that look like the
inputs themselves so if you if you give
the model a text like cat it will
produce cat images or dog images
for instance here so these are two very
different kinds of models
um and the Dilemma that uh that I want
to put in the center in the stock is
that uh discriminative machine learning
models can be brittle
um and I'm sure a lot of people in this
audience are are familiar with things
like adversarial um adversarial attacks
where you can have a model uh that
predicts this picture to be the picture
of a pig
um with high confidence uh but then if
you add a small amount of a specific
kind of noise to this to this input the
same model with high with high
probability predicts this to be the
picture of an airliner for instance uh
so so discriminative models sometimes
can provide uh predictions and
probabilities that uh that tend to be
unreliable uh there is a lot of research
in this domain and a lot of different uh
different hypotheses of uh of why this
might be happening uh but there is one
specific hypothesis that I want to focus
on uh which is that discriminative
machine learning models are brittle uh
because they do not model the
distribution of the inputs they do not
model P of X so to understand that uh
what discriminative models do is that
they model the conditional probability
of targets uh given inputs so the model
P of Y given X
um but uh but on the other hand if we
look at generative models uh they just
don't model P of Y given X they model P
of Y and X uh that would mean the model
P of Y given X as well as P of X and how
this helps is if they are faced with
unfamiliar inputs which we can call out
of domain inputs
um that the model has not seen in the
training data then discriminative models
per predict with this P of Y given x o d
and that leads to unreliable predictions
um or unreliable probabilities or
confidence with the with the predictions
whereas generative models do know that P
of X oeds itself is small because that
data is not uh is not something they
have seen previously and so the P of Y
given xod will also be small so they are
able to uh sort of put probability uh
probability estimates on things that
they don't know about and they can be
robust in that in that manner um so with
that line of thinking uh there has been
a lot of research in machine learning uh
in the field of generative modeling
which has led to us living in the age of
really great uh and deep generative
models so we can have models like like
Dali which I'm sure many of you are
familiar with which can produce images
based on and text inputs so maybe the
input here was was was avocado chair and
then Dali produces all of these images
which are which are really very
realistic looking and and correspond to
the text input that has been provided uh
and there are text generation uh models
as well like GPT Bert and all their
descendants uh so these models are
amazing there's been a lot of great
research in this domain and they produce
really realistic looking inputs but
one of the issues that that continues is
that these models do not really uh um do
not really get us uh too robust and
robust and interpretable machine
learning models
um and that and that's the case because
of two different reasons the the first
one being that the that it is not clear
for these generative models what are the
parameters or features that they are
using to generate the data uh so we
don't have really an insight into uh
into the data generative process and
it's not clear how the data is being
generated in the first place
um so what would be a much better
situation to have would be a generative
model where we can directly specify uh
parameters of consequence uh we could
think of these as hypothesized causal
factors we can think about as as
scientists we can think about
um about the process we are studying and
we can hypothesize factors that matter
and uh if we can build a generative
model out of that that would be great
that's what we want to do in addition
one thing that is hard with many of the
generative models uh that uh that that
we have today is that it's not very
clear how we can use the generated data
in Downstream discriminative tasks any
sort of the downstream task
um and that's because it's hard to
calculate for for many of these models
this P of uh the the probability of any
text in any test input that we that we
provide to the model
um because that the from a Bayesian
perspective that would be an integration
over the parameters of the model uh over
the posterior uh that we have over the
parameters and since the parameters
themselves are not really interpretable
um this is a hard thing to do this it's
not clear how we would do this so if we
had a generative model where we can
specify the parameters of consequence
and in addition if we could do Bayesian
posterior inference uh over uh over the
parameters of that generative model that
would be a great situation for us and
that can get us uh some way towards
towards the robust and the robots and
interpretable machine learning models
and systems
um and today I want to argue to you that
uh that are really common and uh and
really really old way of modeling which
is common across many science and
engineering Fields uh might be the
answer might be a possible answer to
this to this dilemma uh and uh and these
models are uh and the models that I want
to talk to you about are are simulation
based generative models
um so these models could be we could
have models for instance uh of of an
aircraft in a wind tunnel where we can
specify uh things like the aircraft's
wingspan and so on
um we could have neural circuit
simulations we could have the universe
simulations for instance and and I'm
sure
most of you are have seen examples of of
such models in any any scientific field
that uh the that you have the that you
have studied uh and it's also related to
the relatively newer concept of digital
twin
but it's not very common to use these
models in a machine learning setting and
in this talk today I want to make an
effort to do that and show you an
example of uh of how we applied these
ideas in a specific use case uh that we
are interested in so to to jump into
that we as um as as industry
professionals and social science
researchers so my collaborators are our
social science researchers
um we are interested in uh why and how
users leave ratings on online platforms
so I don't have to convince anyone In
This Crowd I'm sure uh that online
reviews and ratings are crucial in
e-commerce and we consult ratings on
websites like Amazon and websites like
TripAdvisor and so many other websites
um and what we wanted to do as
researchers is to is to design a
generative model uh of how users leave
online ratings uh and we wanted to do
this ground up uh using consequential
parameters like the cost to leaving a
rating uh or the herding of users
opinions of products so how are how is a
user's opinion of a product affected by
other users opinions about the same
product
um so we wanted to use these parameters
and and build as a generative model
um and that we did using a generative
simulation model so what we built is is
called an agent based generative
simulation of ratings on an online
Marketplace
um and agent-based simulations are are
super common in the social sciences so
this is not a new idea at all but we
built a specific one uh for our use case
here so what we have here is an agent
you can think of it as a user uh who
comes on the marketplace
um which has a lot of products and using
uh using some sort of a user product
similarity measure which we do by
calculating user and product embeddings
using start space which is a tool I
would encourage you to look into if you
are interested in that domain so the
user uses this similarity measure to to
to consider a set of products that they
might buy today so maybe today they are
interested in electronics and these are
the products they have in their in their
consideration set then they calculate a
score over the products in the
consideration set which is a mixture of
the similarity that the user has towards
each of the each of the products sort of
how much are they interested in each of
these products uh plus the average
rating of the product which is a
reflection of the quality of the product
and using that score the user calculates
a choice probability based on which the
user selects one product the headphone
in this case uh that they choose to buy
so assume that the user the this user
came in and bought a headphone on this
on this Marketplace
um once this this uh this decision to
purchase is done then the user goes on
to to decide whether or not to rate the
product and this is how that happens the
the user looks at the existing ratings
of the product and based on that the
user forms an expectation about the
quality of the product and buys the
product
um and then they listen to music from
the headphone and and they have a real
experience they the the they actually
experience the product and that can lead
to to a discrepancy it can there can be
a discrepancy between what they had
expected based on the ratings that they
saw before buying the product
um and either and their actual real
experience and based on this discrepancy
they make the decision of leaving a
rating or not so if the discrepancy is
small if the if if their reality and
their expectation are well matched then
they decide not to leave a rating they
think that it maybe is not worth the
effort to post a rating but if they have
a really good experience much better
than expected they might leave a
five-star rating they have a really bad
experience they might leave a one star
rating and we make these decisions in
our models using these parameters which
we call Cost parameters row plus and row
minus
um which uh basically control uh the the
the the end to which this the the which
basically control how large this
discrepancy has to be for the user to
leave a rating and what sort of reading
they will leave so so as you can see
these are parameters that are of
consequence in the actual uh decision
making uh process of the user eventually
in the model that we actually built
there are eight model parameters uh per
simulated product so there are the cost
parameters that I talked to you about
already there is a propensity of herding
which is to what extent is the user's
opinion of a product affected by the
already existing ratings when they are
trying to lever rating
um we have a bunch of threshold
parameters which which uh which control
uh how many stars are there in the
rating that the user leaves and we have
a bias uh towards five-star ratings
because a lot of users on online
platforms just leave five star ratings
irrespective of their of their
experience
um so with these parameters uh uh with
the these are parameters built out of
hypothesis we have about out the about
the data generating process and now we
have a generative model out of this
um so so putting this all together uh we
have we are we are working on on a
python package to make this accessible
as well uh what we can do is we have we
have a Marketplace simulator class for
instance uh sorry uh and once we once we
pass in the parameters uh that that we
want to have in the simulation we are
able to simulate data and what that
means is on out the other side we get
actual time series of ratings uh so the
time series of one two three four five
uh per product as the output
um and so this uh with all of this we
have a generative model with
interpretability built in because
um because we have built in something
that we uh that we talked about at the
start we have a generative model where
we have been able to directly specify uh
parameters of consequence we have been
able to specify these these these cost
parameters or these Harding parameters
which really matter in this process we
are we are studying
um so I hope to have convinced you that
that simulation based models do fulfill
that role
um but the question Still Remains uh um
about how we can do Bayesian posterior
inference in these models
um uh because we do we because we know
from the generative models that we have
right now we can generate really good
data but they are not interpretive
interpretable so we don't have both of
these uh both of these criteria met in
any of the generative models we have can
we achieve that for for the simulation
based uh generative models
um and it turns out we can do that
that's what uh the the that's what we
did in our application case as well
um but before we jump into that uh I
want to uh talk to you about uh why
Bayesian inferences is so hard for for
generative simulation models um and the
reason for that is that when we are
doing based inference uh we are trying
to infer a posterior over the model
parameter so we want to get the P of
parameters given the data and to do this
um we need two pieces of information we
need the prior over the parameters which
is always available because that's
something we specify ourselves as
modulers and we also leave the
likelihood which is the P of data given
parameters which is usually defined by
the model so if you have something like
a linear regression the straight line
itself defines this likelihood but if
you think about it if you take a moment
and think about it
um we do not have access to this
likelihood function for the generative
simulations these uh in our agent based
simulation for instance we can have a
Marketplace we can bring users into the
marketplace we can simulate ratings from
that Marketplace but we cannot write
down this likelihood function and that's
why we we need to perform likelihood
free Bayesian inference which is much
harder to do than the standard uh ways
of doing Beijing inference and that is
also
where my the where the title of my talk
of my talk comes from
so with that uh uh we also have an
additional challenge in our specific use
case that our likelihood free inference
uh setup needs to scale with the with
the size of the marketplaces per product
catalog which can be hundreds or even
thousands of product
um of products and it turns out that uh
some really interesting research in the
last couple of years in in in the field
of probabilistic machine learning uh has
helped with addressing this problem so
we use this this method called
sequential neural posterior estimation
or snpe which is a relatively new method
published in the last two to three years
and the authors of this of this project
had have also developed a really well uh
well-constructed toolbox to be able to
use the algorithms that they have
published about uh which is another
example of how well designed software uh
uh is
um allows for accessible and open signs
and allows us to practice is to apply
these algorithms to our use cases so how
does SNP work so what it does is
basically it trains a posterior
estimator from the simulated data so
what it does essentially is we uh we the
the that it trains
some sort of neural network to which we
input the simulated uh product ratings
so that goes in from one side and on the
other side we get the posterior over the
parameters
um but keep in mind that this is this
the the output over here uh is a complex
and high dimensional probability
distribution it's an eight dimensional
probability distribution in our case and
it's not the usual sort of uh output
that we have in regression or
classification problems um and given
this is a high dimensional and complex
distribution it's not very easy to
parameterize it uh in in any form so
what SNP does is that it uses actually
deep generative models uh specifically
normalizing flows to help in this in
this situation so we have the generative
models that I talked about right at the
start of the top coming back here but in
a different role uh so they are not
generating data here but they are
inferring the posterior distributions
for other more interpretable generative
models uh the simulation models that we
that we talked about so how normalizing
flows work is that they begin with a
simple distribution maybe a gaussian
which I should show on the left over
here
um and apply repeated Transformations uh
to eventually convert that simple
distribution into the complex
distribution that we are trying to model
which is our eight dimensional posterior
distribution
um the trick here is that each of these
Transformations is is parameterized by a
neural network so it's trainable by by
uh with with training data and that's
where that's where the machine learning
part in this whole process comes in
um so with all of that set up we just
need to in our specific use case we need
to add one more thing
um which is that we have to input uh the
rating time series uh into the s p
network uh so so so so the input in our
case is is time series of ratings for
different products and if you think
about it these time series uh do not
have a fixed length so you cannot there
is nothing in a Marketplace controlling
how long the rating time series for a
for a product would be so to be able to
embed them to us to a fixed Dimension we
use 1bcnns
um and we are able to train these 1D
cnns together with the with the
posterior estimating normalizing flow
and so that's great about this setup
that we can use this as one big neural
network and train it in one go
um we evaluate the performance of the
entire inference network uh by using
predictive log likelihood on a held out
set of simulations uh so we input the
one once this training procedure is done
we can input an actual time series of
product ratings from from a real
Marketplace and we can get the eight
dimensional posterior out the other side
um and so
with that we are able to use this this
way of doing Bayesian inference in our
in our specific use case as well uh and
we have set it up in our in our code
base as well that uh once we feed in the
parameters and we feed in the
simulations then we can infer the s p
posterior
um and um and and once the posterior has
been inferred uh we can feed in as a
real data to get posteriors uh uh for
the that are specific to individual
products so the real data that we use
are uh our ratings data from from a UK
based online retailer that we already
had in hand
um uh one of the other really great
things about this setup is that the
inference Network needs to be trained
only once on this on the simulated
Marketplace data um so we don't have to
train it for every product uh each uh
for each and every one of the hundreds
or or or thousands of products that we
that we might have in our data set we
have about 1400 products uh we train it
once and then we can do amortized
inference as it's called Uh using the
same train Network across the entire
catalog and and that's a great uh the
great property to have so now we have
the posterior distribution over the
parameters we have a generative model
that is interpretable we have a
posterior distribution over the
parameters of the model uh how how do we
use that so we can do a lot of different
things and I'll just give you a couple
of examples of what we do in our project
for instance so we could do something
like this we could plot out the product
specific eight-dimensional posterior
distributions so this is the posterior
distribution of an individual product it
is a dimensional but I'm showing you
pair plots of of of pairs of parameters
uh in this distribution so we have the
parameters on the left over here and we
can say interesting things uh about this
product so for this specific product for
instance we can say that leaving a
positive rating is easier than leaving a
negative rating
um and that we can say because if we
look at the marginals of rho plus and
row minus the first two top marginal so
over here the marginal mode of row plus
is much smaller
compared to the marginal mode of rho
minus so the cost to leaving a positive
rating is smaller than the cost to
leaving a negative rating so these are
directly interpretable things we can say
right out of the of the model we have
built
um we could even go one step further
into into Downstream predictive tasks
um and this is also a standard Bayesian
way of doing this where we sample from
the posterior to uh to to produce
predictions and that is called a
posterior predictive distribution
sometimes also called posterior
predictive checks for instance and what
we are doing here is that we are running
the simulation model using parameters
sampled from the inferred posteriors and
this is functionality we have put into
our code base also that we can sample
from the inferred product specific eight
dimensional posterior for each user who
comes to buy and review and we just we
can just input the simulation parameters
uh into the simulate method and it is
able to sample from that and this is
fundamentally different actually from
how simulation models are used uh uh
yeah are usually used because usually
you fix the simulation parameters in one
go and then you simulate but here we are
sampling from a probability distribution
while simulating so that's additional
functionality we have put into our into
our code base as well and when we do
that we can do things like this so This
figure here uh shows the moving average
rating of a particular product
um and in Black over here are 20 uh
um
in Black over here is the moving average
rating over 20 ratings from uh from a
particular product from about 20 ratings
for a for a particular product and these
ratings were not seen by the SNP uh
training procedure
um we we trained uh the SNP procedure
using the other ratings of this the the
previous ratings of this product and
then we simulated out into the future
and one example simulation is shown in
red over here so we did 32 simulations
one out of the 32 is shown in red over
here and in blue with the error bars
which is mean plus standard deviation uh
we have the mean plus standard deviation
of the 32 simulations that we did and we
we can see that these all you know fall
on top of each other so uh the
simulation model is able to reproduce uh
the data that looks like real data
um and in this rating prediction task
which is a particularly hard task we see
about a seven percent Improvement in
rmsc across all products uh using the
simulation model over here compared to a
baseline which has been built out of
multinomial predictions from rating
count histograms which is usually what
you would do
um hi Narendra yeah apologies for
interrupting you have about two minutes
left in in your talk would you like to
leave some time to fill some questions
I think I'll finish this and maybe take
it on Discord
okay sure so uh yeah so I hope uh I have
uh
um I have convinced you that that
generative simulations can can fulfill
uh both of the of of the criteria that
we started out with uh so with that I'll
end my talk and uh um and and just give
special thanks to the to the Google
Cloud academic research grant for
computing resources for this project uh
and also to tilburg science hub for RA
support on our project uh until work
science serve is a really uh interesting
open science collaboration here in the
Netherlands uh they are giving a
lightning talk on Saturday which I
encourage you guys to go to if you are
interested in in open science and all
that uh and thanks a lot for your time
and uh I don't know if we still have
time for questions or I'll be available
on Discord as well